welcome to Simon Dev this is gonna be
the start of a new series of tutorials
on terrain generation which is a really
cool topic that's interested me for a
really long time over the course of the
series what I plan to do is step by step
filled out an increasingly complex
terrain generation system all from
scratch building from a simple plane to
a complex three-dimensional world with
near infinite detail different climates
and biomes oceans rivers forests Tundra
that kind of thing maybe even weather
effects past that I've always wanted to
make a full universe simulator something
along the lines of no man's sky but with
a focus on the worlds and being able to
explore the universe hopefully this
gives me an excuse to work towards that
what we'll start with today is just
getting the basics down understanding
how to start by using a simple plane how
to modify it to add height then how to
read and sample from a height map
manually and apply that to the terrain
I'm using 3GS to get things started but
in reality you could easily reuse the
code and approach in unity Godot C++
excetera
what's important is understanding the
approach the code is all available on
github so take a look if you're
interested the link is in the
description below and like always if
anything doesn't make any sense feel
free to comment below what we're going
to go over today I'll show you how to
get started with all of this beginning
with a simple plain will explain how it
gets mutated in order to get the effect
we want which in this case is terrain so
let's get going the first thing we want
to do is get a plane up on the screen
which will act as the ground so you see
here I've got a plane and it's acting a
sort of ground that we'll start with
you'll notice that the plane is flat it
doesn't have any curves or bumps or
anything which is what we're looking to
add so what you have to do is edit the
vertices of the plane see the plane is
made up of vertices and in this case
there are four vertices and we need to
modify them with different height values
in order for a plane to be anything but
flat so here we can see what I do is go
and change the high
for each one to a correspond to whatever
height we want if we want mountains we
push them higher if we want hills we
push them though not quite as high and
remember that each point is 3d specified
with x y&z coordinates so we'll only
need to modify the y coordinate since
we're using y is the up in our world X
is left and right and that is forward
backwards what we do is loop through
each of the vertices and we modify the y
coordinate to change the height and once
we do that we can see the plane instead
of being totally flat now it reflects
the change in height in the corner over
there but there's only four vertices so
this isn't going to give us much in the
way of rolling hills and mountains and
so you can only sort of flare out the
flaps right now if I switch to wireframe
mode here you can see that there's only
four vertices and two faces two
triangles there's very little to work
with here what we need is resolution so
we need two tessellate this thing
meaning we need instead of just two
vertices on each side we need a lot more
I'm going to crank it up to 256 by 256
this looks exactly the same except that
when we switch to wireframe mode this is
massively more tessellated in fact the
individual faces now are so small that
we kind of have to zoom in to see them
which is perfect this will work great
for the demo now we go and modify the
vertices I'll go and modify that corner
again the whole thing basically looks
flat except for that one little corner
which is flaring up again that's perfect
so instead of just raising one corner
let's create a giant Hill in the middle
of the terrain using code what I'm doing
here is I'm looping over every vertex in
the mesh and will calculate the distance
from the middle of the terrain and the
closer we are to the middle the higher
the land will be this smoothing function
here is just a modified smooth step
function taken here from Wikipedia Ken
purlins improvement on the smooth step
function
and once we do that we get this cool
Hill in the middle that sort of falls
off closer to the sides of the tile and
it all looks pretty smooth since there's
sufficient resolution in the mesh now
I'm only doing this demonstration on how
to modify the terrain this isn't how
we're going to be forming mountain
ranges and that sort of thing it just
shows you how to modify the mesh the
next step will be to take some sort of
data source and for this tutorial we're
going to be using a height map
I'll just jet over here quickly to [ __ ]
and let's make a quickie height map
generally for height maps black and RGB
is zero zero zero and that corresponds
to the lowest points on the terrain and
white or 255 255 255 is the highest
point and so I'll just fill in the
canvas with black and take the brush and
draw some stuff back in the code what we
need to do is read in the height map and
then read in the pixel data then you
need to map every point on the train to
a point on the height map meaning for
every vertex you need to map it to XY
coordinates for a pixel on the height
map now here's the ever so slightly
tricky part that you can just take
wholesale from my code if you want the
mesh and the height map aren't
necessarily going to be the same
resolution if my height map is 50 by 50
pixels and my mesh is 100 by 100 you
need to blend pixels together in a
process called bilinear filtering this
is super complex looking it's actually
not that complex but this does an
incredible job of making a simple the
idea into an unapproachable complex one
this is the exact same filtering that's
done for you by the GPU when you're
sampling textures in say a shader it's
the same thing by linear filtering it's
just that here we don't get to rely on
the GPU to implement them for us since
we have to do this manually in code
which is great because we get to learn
how this works Wikipedia is great for
in-depth knowledge but crap for
explaining it in a straightforward way
so let's go over how to do bilinear
filtering manually since we'll need a
sample from the height map given a point
inside this group of four pixels by
linear filtering all that's doing is
figuring out the con
mission of those for an easy way is to
first for the top and bottom rows figure
out how far left and right you are as a
percentage and then blend between the
left and right colors and that gives you
two new colors who calls these P X 1 and
P X 2 and then once you've calculated
those two values you figure out how far
between the top and bottom you are so
given 4 pixels you perform two blends
from left to right and then one final
blend between the top row and bottom row
blended values giving you a final pixel
value so now we know exactly how to
blend values from the height map to
match our vertex positions it's just a
matter of looping through all the
vertices in the mesh looking up each
value in the height map reading back the
pixel data and then using it to modify
the height what this code does here
steps to reach vertex in the mesh and
then using the x ed coordinates it does
a lookup from the height map reading the
pixel data now remember the pixel data
is three separate values RGB or
sometimes for RGB a a being alpha and
each value is a byte that's between 0
and 255 what we want is we want to scale
this to the range 0 & 1 by dividing by
255 and then we multiply by the maximum
height that we want for the height map
you can see here that once we've done
all that we've got a chunk of terrain
here that roughly matches the picture we
drew now if we're going to do procedural
infinite worlds though we're not going
to be height mapping everywhere at least
not using height maps we draw ourselves
so in the next tutorial we'll look at
procedurally generating the height map
using fractal Brownian motion composed
of overlapping layers of purlins or
simplex noise this is one of those
things that sounds super complicated but
it's really not what we'll be doing is
we'll take our terrain we'll generate a
bunch of random nonsense but in a really
specific way and we'll treat it as our
height map and voila we'll have
something that's starting to look
realistic that about wraps up part 1 of
this I showed you how to create a height
map and then apply that to a tessellated
plane to create a
of train as I said in the next update
we'll be continuing on this course but
we'll learn about Perlin noise simplex
noise and how those are all related to
fractal Brownian motion for now I hope
this was easy to follow and if you
enjoyed this video and want to see more
like it give it a like and hit that
subscribe button in the corner also let
me know what you'd like to see in the
future by leaving a comment below until
next time cheers everyone